welcome to the interval and long now I'm
Alexander Rose the executive director
here at long now
and
um I'm so happy to be doing this event
tonight and as some of you may know
we're also doing another event tomorrow
where the actual piece uh that we took
up the mountain will be at Gallery 308
and we'll be able to have 250 of you
there if you want to come to that and
Off the Grid we'll be doing their food
trucks outside which is also an awesome
uh thing to do in Fort Mason so please
do join us for that if you would like
this is also
the very first uh kind of pilot of a
fellowship program that we are working
on for the future uh with long now and
we've spent the last 25 26 years in a
way
bringing people to us to talk out
towards you
but the next 25 years we're trying to
find people in their own communities
that are doing very interesting work in
long-term thinking that
can
create their own spaces and their own
communities and do that and so this is
the very first version of that and uh
when
I think it was a Twitter connection that
got made between uh
our speaker tonight and Stuart about a
quote that he had and when we started
talking about it
I said well you know we have this
mountain that has some of the oldest
trees in the world on it and this would
be a really amazing quote to bring up
there and so the culmination of that was
this project that we were able to do uh
with Alicia and it was very uh
challenging in terms of logistics it's
an 11 000 foot Mountain uh with a very
difficult four-wheel drive Road uh that
was very weather dependent it's very
delicate neon all of those things and it
all kind of came together and was one of
the most amazing uh days that we have
ever had on this mountain so with that
please join us Alicia Eggert
[Applause]
well for being here
um I just want to say that this is such
a huge honor
um because I've been a like a
like a fan of this organization for so
long
um I can't believe I am speaking to some
of the people in this room so thank you
thank you so much
oh
okay so as a conceptual artist I have
always gravitated to language as a
material I like to think I sculpt words
the way that other sculptors work with
wood or stone
um and the reason I like to use language
and give words tangible physical forms
in space is because I believe we might
be able to understand an idea more fully
if we can experience it physically
not only do I use language to express
meaning I also take advantage of the way
that meaning can be embedded in a
material and the way that each material
I work with has its own duration or
lifespan
and I explore everything from cut
flowers to welded steel which is a much
more kind of traditional sculpture
material
and meaning is also embedded in the
processes I choose to use so for
instance sculpting additively is much
different than sculpting subtractively
and in this example the word future
because it's removed from a larger form
becomes a negative space or a void
I also love the way that viewing
sculpture is a very embodied experience
the work inhabits your physical space
and you can walk around it and see it
from multiple perspectives and your
individual perspective as a viewer
really matters actually it helps to
shapes The Works meaning and in this
case it you know determines the way you
see the future
because my work is text-based
um naturally drawn to using the
materials and strategies that are often
used in commercial signage so I'm
inspired by all kinds of signs including
road signs and like reflective vinyl and
the colors that are used in those and
I'm drawn to the material and the medium
of neon for all the obvious reasons you
know nothing compares to that quality of
light emitted by electrified gases that
are trapped in a you know glass tube but
neon is also actually very sculptural
the glass tubes are heated and bent over
a flame and they're often bent back on
themselves in order to create a specific
shape
but my favorite thing about neon signs
is animating them and the way it allows
me to bring them to life literally and
the flashing is obviously designed to
sort of grab your attention but I also
like to use it to create a specific
rhythm in the work the pace is
intentionally slow enough so that you
can read The Works messages but it's
also fast enough to hold your attention
and keep you present and also make you
aware of times passing
um it's similar for me to like the
rhythm of breath uh in mindfulness
meditation
my desire to give time a tangible
physical form
um actually started with this project
that I did in graduate school I called
it the length of now and when I did a
Google search of that term is when I
discovered the long now foundation and
became a member I think it was like 2008
right
um but this project involved cutting
pieces of red yarn to really specific
lengths and then soaking them in water
and then freezing them into the shape of
the word now and then taking them out of
the freezer and hanging them on a nail
on a wall and then allowing them to melt
um and I made videos of those Nows
melting
um because each one was unique right and
I projected a video uh my favorite video
onto the wall with a clock
um in order to juxtapose our lived
experience of time with our perception
of time and also with that sort of
measured mechanical clock time
and this video of now that I chose
really highlighted for me how our
awareness of time passing is linked to
our perception of motion
so there were long moments where the
word appears static and change is like
pretty imperceptible and time feels slow
and really stretched and then when you
begin to perceive the motion you have
this heightened sense of anticipation of
something just about to happen and then
in moments of more abrupt change time
seems to speed up right and it was
interesting also to try to identify at
which point the word now was no longer
now but no or Nothing at All
foreign
my fascination with time uh probably
stems from the fact that my dad was a
pastor so I was raised in church and I
was constantly reminded of the
inevitability of my death and the
possibility of an eternal afterlife
right
um but instead of believing in an
afterlife I ended up becoming an atheist
and I'm much more inclined to believe
something the philosopher Ludwig
Wittgenstein said which is that eternal
life belongs to those that live in the
present
uh and since the definition of Eternity
is timelessness what better material is
there to create it than clocks right by
Nature the motion of clock hands is
cyclical and potentially infinite
um the hour hand goes around once every
oh sorry the minute hand goes around
once every hour and the hour hand goes
around once every 12 hours and it's only
then that we see this word eternity
uh that video is high speed you know
time lapse but when you actually
experience this work in person you
perceive it as a static object so the
you know the motion of those minute
hands is just on the limits of our
perception
and in contrast to that sort of cyclical
mechanical time the reality of our lived
experience of time is very linear and
finite and I'm drawn to the ways in
which we measure that kind of time in
our daily lives like with the height
charts that we keep on the walls of our
houses when our children are growing up
so this one on the screen is actually
inspired by my own son's height chart
he's eight years old now and last year I
actually asked him you know how tall do
you think you're going to be when you
grow up and I asked them to point to
that spot on the wall and I drew a line
there and I wrote someday and then the
height that he was at that exact moment
became now and then all the moments
before and after now are then right
thank you
and it's interesting to think about how
when we're children we count time up but
then at a certain point when we get
older we start to count time down
um and time becomes ultimately a
reminder of our mortality and our hearts
are like ticking clocks
so this is a sculpture that has an
average human lifespan that I called
pulse machine
and the drum is the heart and it beats
its pulse and the counter on the wall
counts down the number of seconds
remaining in the sculpture's lifetime
and it uses those flip digit numerals
from old scoreboards that remind me of
like the ventricles of a heart and the
sculpture is programmed to die when the
counter reaches zero
it's a little bit like pose Telltale
Heart kind of reminding us of the
inevitability of death and some people
have told me it's like a little dark or
creepy
um but I actually believe that
um thinking about time more deeply and
more regularly encourage us encourages
us to live more meaningfully
you know it reminds us to focus on more
important things instead of more urgent
things you know and what's more urgent
than death
I actually enjoy putting my work in
public spaces for this very same reason
um to give people more opportunities to
think about time deeply in their daily
lives public art allows people to
encounter art in unexpected situations
and in the real world and in real time
and that same specific experience is
very very different from the experience
that you have with our in a gallery or a
museum which are spaces that are
typically you know designed to be
outside of time they sort of pluck
objects out of the real world sometimes
unethically and put them in these boxes
that often don't even have Windows where
objects are you know preserved for
posterity and a lot of my work as an
artist is actually driven by my desire
to sort of push back against that
expectation that Society has of artists
to make work that will last forever
um and the sense of place afforded by a
specific site I think provides context
for
um The Works message right so and not
just in like a static or a singular way
um the work and it's meaning are
impacted by continuous changes in the
environment in the light and the
atmospheric conditions
the sense of timelessness implied by
this word forever is contracted is
contrasted by you know our observable
time in the landscape
um and it was very much inspired by that
phrase on a clear day you can see
forever right
um but I love the way that when fog
rolls in it literally erases everything
in sight you know and I love that the
way our perception of space changes also
sort of affects the way we perceive time
um and this way of experiencing art like
out in the real world is not only visual
it engages all of our senses
so in this case the appearance and
disappearance of this word in the fog is
coupled with those crashing waves and
the birds flying by sometimes and those
repetitive blaring fog horns
um side note I did this project in Maine
in 2016 and it actually only stayed up
for about three weeks
um but I'd love to find a way to bring
it here to the Bay Area also
so one of the wonderful things for me
about light as a medium is the way that
it illuminates everything around it
right so when I place a neon sign in a
specific environment not only does the
site impact the work but the work also
impacts the site and it casts its light
and the color like on everything it can
touch
um and in the same way that turning one
little word on and off in a sentence can
dramatically change what that sentence
is communicating
installing the same sign in a very
different place can also completely
change the way that it's interpreted so
being on a remote island like in the
Mediterranean is very different from
being on the island of Manhattan
so I read books for inspiration
um and I specifically look for books
um you know that are written from the
perspective of physics or philosophy
about the way we understand time and it
was just very natural for me to read
Stuart's book The Clock of the long now
when I became a member of the long now
Foundation
and I was captivated by this quote which
if you've never read the book you should
but it's printed very large in the back
of the book and this was actually a
photograph I took of the quote and
posted on Instagram many years ago
um but the way that I work is when I'm
reading I like have my notebook nearby
and I write down the quotes or the ideas
that really inspire me
um but I sort of put those away and put
them to the side and then it's usually
many years later when I'm brainstorming
ideas for new work or creating new work
for an exhibition that I go back through
old sketchbooks and try to look for
something that really jumps out to me in
that moment and feels relevant at that
time
so it was actually many many years later
after I read the clock of long now that
I went back through old sketchbooks as I
Was preparing for an exhibition and I
came across the quote and I started to
brainstorm ways I could illuminate it
and animate it
um and in order to ask for Stewart's
permission to use it I decided to tweet
this rendering at him and obviously it's
a very initial rendering the sign ended
up looking nothing like this it was my
first attempt at how how what it would
look like right but I tweeted this at
Stuart because it's amazing how
something like Twitter gives you access
to people that you wouldn't normally
have access to right
but I want to pause real quick at this
point in the story and talk about the
relationship between possibility and
reality because another one of long
now's co-founders Brian Eno once said
that humans are capable of a unique
trick
creating realities by first imagining
them
and I really believe this to be true
actually I also believe that our sense
of possibility is directly correlated to
our conception of time so the more
expansively we think about the here and
now the larger our sense of possibility
and I'm also interested in the
transformation of possibility into
reality when does it switch from you
know only being possible to actually
being real
um so at this time when I tweeted at
Stuart you know the sign was still just
in the realm of possibility
um and I could imagine it but it was
very possible that he would say no or he
would just ignore me altogether right
um but if you know Stuart you probably
know that I didn't even need to ask for
his Blessing because he gives it freely
so as you can see here he ended up
tweeting back at me just a few minutes
later literally and he said sure
so this is the first edition of this
present moment that I made for an
exhibition I had in Portugal in 2019 and
as you can see the design changed
dramatically from my initial rendering
um because at some point I realized I
could turn off those two words present
and unimaginable and I could reveal
another kind of complete statement this
moment used to be the future and when I
realized that I knew I had to align all
the text on the left hand side so that
when those words disappeared there
wasn't like a gaping hole right in the
design
and the color pink was also a very
deliberate Choice
um I take color very seriously and
um I chose pink at that time in 2019
because of the Ripple effects that the
metoo movement was having on the world
and I personally was trying to imagine
what the world would look like if it was
more Equitable and more safer for women
and girls and I also wanted to imagine
you know a future where the color pink
wasn't always just associated with women
and girls
um and it's crazy to think back on this
time because here we are three years
later I never could have imagined that
we'd be living in a post-row world right
um but after sharing that finished work
with Stuart again on Twitter I found out
that this quote actually is co-authored
um with Stuart's friend and poet Gary
Snyder who wrote this epigram and shared
it with Stuart inspiring him to write
the quote that inspired me so I really
love this backstory and it's beautiful
for me to see how this sentiment has
evolved over time and how I am now a
part of that evolution
but I make three editions of each neon
sign
um so that I can share them with more
people in the world and actually put
them more places in the world and later
that same year I made a second edition
that ended up being acquired by the
smithsonian's Renwick gallery and around
that same time I started having
conversations with Xander as he said
about where in the world we could bring
this sign that would be a meaningful
place to the organization
and it was around that time that I
learned about this property on Mount
Washington in Nevada and the fact that
it's the home to some of the Earl some
of the world's longest living trees the
Bristlecone Pines some of which have
lived over 5 000 years
um so in the fall of 2021 I actually had
the opportunity to do a site visit with
a small group of people from long now
and uh you know drive trucks up to the
top of the mountain and actually
experience those Bristlecone Pines in
person and to learn more about them and
to start to conceive of like how
bringing a neon sign to that remote
location might be possible
so um that process of actually imagining
what we're about to do and then making a
reality took about a year
um and it involved making a third
edition of the neon sign with my studio
assistant Jess Greene in my studio in
Dallas Texas
and I made this sign specifically for
this opportunity so
um the the scale of it and also the way
that it's constructed in modular
components so that it can easily
assemble and disassemble
um so here you can see it in the back of
a pickup or sorry a moving truck
um and the sign structure is made of
steel right and all of the glass
components are stored in that wood crate
and I just want to take a second to
acknowledge the fact that we use glass
for this specific project because it's
kind of insane
honestly and the most insane part about
it is that I didn't make any backups
so we only had one piece of glass for
each part of the sign and if any of them
broke along the way we would have been
screwed but we probably would have found
ways of making it still happen but that
material that materiality of glass was
actually a really important part of this
project for me because I think it really
speaks to that fragility of like
possibility reality relationships right
and it's interesting to think about when
you know the culmination of an idea
draws nearer and we could we've been
planning for a year and we can now
really imagine what this sign is going
to look on this what it's going to to
look like on this mountain top but the
closer we got to actually making that a
reality the more fragile that sense of
possibility actually became because one
broken letter could have like totally
made it potentially impossible
and one of the most significant
challenges as you can see here was
getting the glass up this mountain
safely up to 11
000 feet it's so interesting to learn
about the Bristlecone Pines and the fact
that they actually thrive in these
really extreme conditions that you can
only find that these you know really
high elevations so it was really
interesting to try to make that Journey
up to this place where they live
um and of course we had to do all these
crazy switchbacks and the road was dirt
and there was all these huge ruts and
every time we went over a bump I was
freaking out inside
um but thankfully I was in really good
hands
um because it was driven up the mountain
in this crazy truck which I learned is
owned by Gary I don't know if he's here
hi Gary
um the front of which I think is like an
old PG e truck or something like that
and the back of which is a pickup truck
but it had literally just driven off the
Playa from burning man to help me drive
up this mountain and I also had like a
whole team of people who were so
equipped and like fully you know
acquainted with installing art projects
in really extreme environments
um so we arrived at the Mountaintop
around noon and after lunch we
immediately got to work assembling the
sign structure and our goal was to have
everything set up by Sunset
um and this video for me really shows
how fast that afternoon seemed to go by
and I think it's kind of funny because
it might be the shortest term project
the long now Foundation has ever done
um but as you can see we did manage to
get the sign up and working right before
the sunset and I'm so thankful we did
um and another artist and also along now
research fellow Jonathan Keats something
that he said about this particular
moment was how it allowed us to witness
the simultaneous simultaneity of so many
different time scales right the flashing
on and off of those words every three
seconds
um the sort of beginning of the cycle
again every nine seconds
coupled with the passing of the clouds
overhead Gathering and parting and then
the change of the light as the sun set
over the course of about an hour and
then we all know you know that's a cycle
that repeats every day
um and all of those things were then
juxtaposed with the lifespans the 5 000
year old old trees that were surrounding
us right
um so it was quite a magical experience
but one thing actually that did not go
according to plan
um was that the electronic flasher that
I typically use to change the states of
those signs that every three seconds
actually didn't work and we couldn't
figure out why we thought it had
something to do with the electricity
coming out of the generator not jiving
with it we couldn't figure it out so
ultimately I had to plug and unplug
these different sections of the neon
sign at this power strip
um and you can see in this video how
determined I was to keep that Rhythm
really consistent for me it's so so so
important that each state of the sign
lasts three seconds not four not two
three seconds right and that it repeats
over and over and over again creating
that really sort of meditative
experience right
um so when you look at this video
imagine me off to the right hand side of
the scene counting One Mississippi two
Mississippi three Mississippi right
um but that sort of meditative and very
Mechanical Rhythm of the sign became
kind of like a ticking clock you know
and that was juxtaposed with our own
lived experiences of time and the length
of our own human lifespans
so people really love to photograph the
sign when it's illuminated of course
right
um but that third state where all the
words turn off for three seconds
um is actually really important for me
um because
um from my point of view it actually
returns our attention to the landscape
and this was especially crucial here in
this really epic landscape right the
Basin and Range Province I actually
learned is home to some of the highest
mountain peaks in the contiguous United
States and that elevated perspective is
also an important conceptual component
of this project because I like to think
that shift in perspective that bird's
eye view that we get from a Mountaintop
as being really similar to that broader
perspective of time right seeing that
longer now
and
you know yet another time scale we can
experience when we look out at that
landscape is like the geological time
scale and the time it takes for
geological forces to stretch the Earth's
crusts and to form a mountain
so as the sun set the Stars began to
appear and I don't know why but for some
reason this was very unexpected you know
when you think about putting an enzyme
on the mountain you think about like the
sunset but I never could have imagined
that the Milky Way the band of the Milky
Way would literally be right behind it
it was beautiful
and this revealed a whole other time
scale that of galaxies you know
and I didn't actually know until the
other day that our galaxy is spinning
did you know that
um and then it takes about 240 million
years to complete one rotation so here
in this one image we have two vastly
different time scales right A present
moment that lasts depending on how you
think of it three seconds or nine
seconds and one that lasts 240 million
years
um I also love to think about the way
that light travels across space and time
right and it's traveling across space
the same way from the stars as it is
from that neon sign and everything that
we're seeing in that present moment is
actually an image of the past right
um and light ended up being such a
perfect medium for this message for that
reason but also for how you know it's a
very Primal experience to gaze at the
stars or to stare into a fire right and
I feel like this sign had a really kind
of similar uh mood that it created
so what I've always loved about this
quote is the way that we can each relate
to it like on a very individual level
and when we think about this present
moment and how it was once unimaginable
we can think about our current
relationships or the kind of current
state of our career
um but I also love how it can also kind
of speak to a more Universal level and
things that are going out going on in
the world that you know affect all of us
um and I like to think about how if this
present moment was once unimaginable how
it naturally makes you wonder and want
to try to imagine you know what the
future will hold so I personally
I'm trying to imagine a future of gender
equality of equal pay right and equal
access to abortions
um wouldn't that be something but
but I wonder what you are all imagining
for the future
I think in moments like this
um which we had sort of gazing out at
the world from a Mountaintop or you
could have gazing up at the stars at
night or that feeling you get when
you're standing in front of a work of
art that like really really moves you
that broader perspective that you get
that bird's eye view or that feeling of
awe Maybe
can give you a new way of understanding
the world right it can give you that
shift in perspective and it can help you
see the bigger here and the longer now
and the roles that we play in it both
individually and also collectively
and I think that that shift in
perspective can actually help us imagine
otherwise unimaginable futures
and this was definitely an unimaginable
future for me at some point
um being able to stand besides Stuart
brand and gaze up at this sign that I
made Illuminating his words
um so I'm really grateful for this
experience I'm also really grateful to
all of these people who participated in
this project
um some of whom are not even pictured
here
um but thank you all for helping make
this moment a reality
[Applause]
okay so next
um all of you know that tomorrow there's
going to be an exhibition opening right
um in gallery 308 right here so tomorrow
I'm actually going to be setting up the
sign uh over there but in addition to
actually showing the physical sign we're
also going to be showing uh two
different videos that were created of
this project one which is a shorter
exhibition video and one that is a
longer sort of documentary
and now we're gonna sort of Debut the
exhibition video here for you and I'm
very grateful to Justin and Shannon for
their work on this so
[Applause]
so I hope you all enjoy
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you yeah
I specifically asked for this glass of
Prosecco
[Laughter]
um yeah so this was it was such an
amazing project to happen over so many
years and then the culmination moment uh
of the actual trip and
raise your hand the folks that were on
this trip we yes so we had some amazing
people every single one of them like
doing doing a project
like this in the high desert and getting
something like this to 11 000 feet and
it was so cold
um and it was it was really amazing just
the team that came together it was It
was kind of one of those strange things
where exactly the right people exactly
the right time
um exactly the right weather uh I mean
it could have been warmer I would have
liked that but it was at least it wasn't
snowing right and so um
it's
I'm curious as I mean you've done many
projects in many remote places and where
does this fit in the scale of the things
that you have done like that uh
uh this was definitely a first for me in
many ways in terms of like the actual
elevation but it's crazy that literally
only two weeks later I took a neon sign
up Kilimanjaro so it was almost like a
sort of
um a trial run for that other project
which was crazy because this was like a
lifelong goal and then I immediately had
to be like okay great that went really
well now I'm on to this next thing
um but yeah I think that the the people
that came together to make it happen
like Gary with his truck and Trey and
Scout and all the other people who were
in The Caravan up the mountain I didn't
mention that Gary's truck actually broke
down along the way too and we like held
this
thing together I didn't even know what
it was but we held it together with zip
ties maybe I'm not sure
um but all those people that were able
to come together and make it possible
were definitely like a I think it's a
testament to the organization you know
and the types of people that it attracts
so
um it was just like a magical experience
to be a part of that
um I see it very much as a collaboration
yeah and I think that I mean our goal
with the um you know doing something
like this fellowship program is to do
things that only
only we could do
with a collaboration
like this where you know you know
very few people have a Mountaintop with
Bristlecone Pines on it and very few
people are doing the kind of work that
you're doing and so the idea that it
could come together and be that unique
and you know we don't want to reproduce
other people's Fellowship programs you
want to do something that can be uh only
done in this way so that I think this
was a kind of a perfect example of that
um but I'd love to talk a little bit
about your process you
um you're a conceptual artist and you
work with all kinds of Artisans and
other people to create a lot of the
stuff
um and it's done through a design
process but you're you don't build
everything correct um and so I'd love to
hear you just talk a little bit about
that yeah for sure so
um as a conceptual artist I definitely
love participating in the physical
process and doing whatever it actually
makes sense for me to do
um so uh in this case
um my assistant Jess and I welded the
steel structure and did all of that
metal fabrication and of course the
design that led to that
um but I do not Bend glass I am not a
neon bender and that's something that at
a certain point in my career it was
actually in graduate school I went to
Alfred University for my MFA and they
have a neon program within the art
school and
um I I was in grad school for two years
and I saw that class and I was like
there is no way I'm going to master that
craft in this short amount of time
especially with the things that I want
to do with the medium so if I wanted to
use it almost like as a a drawing tool
then maybe it would have made more sense
but because I knew I wanted to create
really specific things like letter forms
it made more sense for me to actually
call upon people who are experts in that
craft and one of those is actually here
in this audience
Ames who's here is a neon vendor here in
San Francisco
and Ames has helped me with um a neon
sign I had at the Exploratorium about a
year ago but Ames is also going to help
with a letter that broke that I
discovered today
um broke at some point either in the
de-installation OR transportation
from the Fort Mason back to storage so
um so yeah for me it's actually
um it's it makes the process more
enjoyable for me to not be only doing it
by myself because I actually feel like
that collaboration with other artists
and experts in their fields
um kind of makes the the project more
successful in the end but it also makes
the process sort of like it makes that
final moment something that you can
celebrate with like a whole group of
people and not just as like sort of this
individual
um and I feel like it's something that
I'm really trying to
um
I think in the art World specifically
we're all used to in music or in film
there's always like credits where
everyone who participated in that
project is acknowledged but for some
reason in the art world it's still we
still have this idea that there's this
like one Soul creative genius behind
everything which is definitely hardly
ever the case anymore so it's something
I'd like to to see change I think so one
of the letters that we're going to show
tomorrow's broken right now
you're gonna help us thank you yeah Ames
is gonna fix it in the morning the
amount of places we brought these
letters and this is the this is the time
between the end of that Dock and here is
where they are broken exactly yeah
um
I'm curious how the uh
I mean your your path in this and and
there's something that is so con
amazingly simple and amazingly profound
about these kind of letter art things
um and so it's how did how did it end up
uh that where the Smithsonian acquired
this first piece
um that is a really good question uh
sometimes like the career trajectory in
the art world still totally baffles me
even you know at this point in my career
I don't understand how decisions are
made like that
um but
um especially since the Renwick gallery
that uh that branch of the Smithsonian
is like a craft institution it's been
collecting craft objects in Wood glass
fibers etc for 50 years and I am
definitely not a craft artist so
um so that is really I don't know I have
no idea
um but it's a huge honor obviously
um and yeah I think that um honestly I
think that in terms of like the
Simplicity the element that you
mentioned about my work
um where that comes from is
um I have this like really strong desire
I think because I didn't grow up in a
family of artists I grew up in like a
norm normal family where they definitely
didn't go to art museums or see
Contemporary Art and be like what I
don't get it you know
um so I I've always had this desire to
make art that everyone can understand at
some really kind of basic level
um but then I think where my where I
really brainstorm and really think about
the combination of the language and the
material and the process is my goal is
to create these layers of meaning that
you can sort of Peel back the longer you
kind of spend with the work and think
about it and think about all of these
elements at Play
yeah I have to say you know as we were
doing this and then you know all the
effort and all the logistics of getting
this to the top of the mountain and not
breaking it and putting it up and and
you know it's a set of words but I think
maybe all of you in the room got a sense
of that when we saw this video it's like
it is so much more than a few words the
moment that it was I mean I was crying
when it happened uh and watching the
video I was like crying again so it was
uh it's like it's uh it's it's
interesting how how it can be so simple
and so powerful at the same time and
it's a credit to the thought that you
put into it
um I think you also told me that
sometimes when you go to you've traveled
with some of these signs that they've
broken and then you have to find a local
Artisan to fix them yeah yeah so the you
are on an island sign I think is the
most well-traveled uh piece that I've
made it was actually made in
collaboration with um a former partner
named Mike Fleming and
um one of our friends at some point was
like you know what I can't believe you
made this work you were on an island you
get to go to all these islands like I
should make something that says you are
on a resort
but we do we have we we've gotten the
opportunity to go to a lot of places
because of that sign and actually
there's like a permanent version of it
on the rooftop of a building in St
Petersburg Russia of all places because
it turns out St Petersburg is a series
of islands who knew
um but uh but yeah what's interesting is
so one of the coolest locations we took
you were on an island was Malta for the
malta Arts Festival I think in 2013 and
um it was there that like as I'm putting
one of the letters up on the sign I I
think I just like
did I don't know I tweaked something a
little weird I torqued the glass in a
way that it didn't like and just like
Snapped it and
um but of course again there were no
backups so immediately we were like okay
so who does neon and Malta right
and it turns out there was one neon shop
um in the country uh and it was run by a
family of three generations a
grandfather a father and a son that had
been doing it for I don't know how long
you know probably close to how long the
medium has even been around
um and so we got to go there you know
bring the broken letter to them so they
could use it to make a pattern and make
a new one and
um it was just the coolest experience to
meet them and to see their shop and then
um at like literally every single neon
person I meet is is so are there some of
the nicest people on the planet so
um it's allowed me to meet some great
people for sure
yeah I like that idea as a travel
principle yeah I had a friend who sold a
story to a magazine saying he wanted to
review all the best first class airplane
things in the world like that was a
really good story to sell right yeah
um uh we have a question from one of the
people who's uh viewing online
um
Michelle and
she's asking uh what was the what was
the the way that you decided to change
the wording like how did that work for
you
um I could have shown so many other
renderings I did like I showed the one
where there's the three lines of text
right that just kind of like turned on
and off in sequence but there were I had
already done that one sign
um that says all the light you see is
from the past right and so I I had
already created that sign which had a
very almost like centered orientation
right and then the two words on the
diagonals turn off and then you read it
kind of across the diagonal
um and then of course I had done that
you are on an island where it's up in
the one corner and it's left hand
oriented
um so there were actually like many
iterations of like how the text could be
aligned which words could turn on and
off
um and and it like it was it wasn't
obvious for some reason that I could
turn off those two words
um so I was like really thinking about
like
other ways of animating it and then it
was just sort of an aha moment I think
at a certain point and then when I tried
to figure out how to turn them off
without making it look weird is when I
discovered that left hand orientation
nice all right we're going to open up
questions in the audience uh raise your
hand and Natasia will bring you a
microphone after this question so James
home who's actually who's our web
designer for long now and was on this
trip and was very uh was helping along
the way he's watching online tonight but
he's asking um
how you mentioned how critical the three
seconds is uh
can you say a little bit more about why
yeah
um well I really felt like when I uh I
animate things in Photoshop and I use
that sort of create a frame animation
tool
um and so I try out different timings
um and it's really about like I try to
read it as if I've never seen the thing
before like this present moment used to
be the unimaginable future and I try to
see like oh did it turn off too soon
before I got you know through the whole
thing so for me it was really about
creating enough time for someone to read
it
um but then not lingering too long for
them to be like and you know attention
is lost
um so that like then almost as soon as
they're done reading it you know it
switches excuse me
um so so it's a lot of play and I think
for this specific sign I was kind of
always between like two and a half and
three seconds and I felt like it was
better to give people a little more time
than to you know have not as much
um so yeah that
that's the gist of it I guess we have a
question anyone have a question for
parents
oh okay
Cassandra
yeah your big sentence here makes me
wonder about different ways in which we
could or could hope to complete an
alternate sentence this present moment
will be the blank past so maybe that can
be the basis of some future art
I love that idea if you write it please
send it to me
that mic is not working oh okay all
right
any other questions from the audience
thanks Liz Beth and a shout out to Texas
when I moved here from Dallas seven
years ago so
time and just think the last couple
years I wondered as you know an artist
just you know what you experienced and
how you went inside and any expression
during the last two years we've really
been in different spaces yeah
um
well yeah I think the so I made this
present moment in 2019 right when I was
in Portugal I think my my exhibition
opening there was in May of 2019 and
then I came back to the United States
and made the second edition at the end
of 2019 maybe September October
and then
um
and then of course 2020 happened and
everything shut down and I didn't
actually make art at all
um during the lockdown
um I live in a part of Texas where
everyone has Lawns and I had a lawn so I
my quarantine project was ripping out
all my grass and planting like a
xeriscape yard and it was amazing uh to
spend time just like with my hands in
the dirt
um
but
uh in 2021 I had an exhibition opening
in Dallas and that was when I made that
steel sculpture with the word future
removed
um so that I actually titled the
unimaginable future still inspired by
Stewart's quote but it was very much
related to my experience during the
pandemic the way that you know my
calendar was so full and then everything
was just wiped like a slate clean right
um so actually just like cutting those
letters out of the steel
um and I didn't talk about this in the
presentation but that sculpture is made
out of rebar which you know is used to
cast different like architectural or
infrastructural elements in concrete and
um uh the larger sculpture that creates
that sort of sense of perspective is
actually tied together with wire the
same way that they tie those kinds of
architectural elements together before
they cast them but
um ultimately like the future is a void
and this whole sculpture is tied
together in such a way that like
something like it was supposed to become
of it and then didn't
um so that was sort of my response to to
that time yeah and I'm gonna
ask Stuart to think if he wants to make
a comment tonight before we close out I
have a couple other questions so I'll
give you a moment and you're also can
say no if you don't want to
um
but I think that
I think what was really interesting I
mean I mean that mountain is is wild in
many ways and that you pointed out and
one of them to me might is the
the root structure of the of those trees
you can see six inches of erosion of the
rock around a living object so they're
like they're more than geologic
which um and so then when you you know
you and the the place that you chose to
put the the sign was a place that
actually some of those trees where a
fire had come through probably hundreds
or possibly a thousand years ago and had
those trees were mostly dead but uh my
favorite comment about bristle cones is
that it's not that they live for a very
long time it's that they take a very
long time to die
and so you'll you'll see a tree that
just has one little strip of bark and a
couple needles on the end
um so seeing seeing that work against
that
um as we also look out across that
landscape was just was very very
powerful
um but I'm just I'm curious you've put
many Works in many Landscapes and like
how how did that feel for you
um I mean to be honest one of the things
that kind of compels me to create this
work is you know my own struggle to
really be present and
um
like you know when everyone else was
like around the fire and like enjoying
the moment I was off to the side like
so so I think like I'm still processing
It ultimately you know like I didn't
really get to fully like feel the
gravity of it at that time and I'm I
will process it probably for a for a
long time to come I think well in the
meantime you took a whole trip to
Kilimanjaro exactly I did take my turn
on the switches with the three
hippopotamus thing but let's hear from
Stuart real quick
uh just a bibliographic note
um
it might will probably be Gary
Schneider's last book of poetry the
title of the book is this present moment
oh because it really got to him
apparently
and I have to say that
the event of that
line in the book
becoming a piece of art that is worth
climbing to the top of the mountain to
show it against a landscape I would say
it was pretty unimaginable
[Laughter]
so thank you for that moment
thank you
indeed and then so you're going to be
here a little bit so if other people
have questions
um and and also so we're gonna uh we'll
we'll break for a moment uh and then
we're gonna clear the chairs and please
if you have a glass on the ground or on
your chair pick it up it makes me very
sad when the all the glassware from
Japan that we import gets broken at this
moment
um so please do that and then we'll but
other people will clean up the chairs
and then we're going to screen the
longer version of the documentary uh not
with sound but with some uh closed
captions uh that's going to be screened
as part of the thing tomorrow night as
well
um but and I want to ask so I do you
have a shot of the Kilimanjaro thing oh
I think so it was kind of you had to use
a different technology than neon in
order to hike it all the way up true I
used LED neon for this one and this is
just an iPhone shot so
um the the shots with the you know DSLR
camera will get more of the Stars and
stuff like that but it was a seven day
climb so we set up the sign at every
Camp along the way
um what was the highest elevation you
got to the 4600 meters meters sorry yeah
awesome and what's your next project
going to be uh well I really hope to do
more with this so this this uh is
inspired by a friend of mine Satya brata
damn is his name and satsya is uh sort
of like a renowned mountain climber he's
climbed all the world's tallest
mountains including Everest like 12
times or something
um but I asked him like what kind of
State of Mind do you have to be to climb
a mountain like that and he said like
you have to be the mountain you can't
see it as an obstacle so
um so that's what inspired this and we
hope to and you know that inspired me to
think about environmental personhood
um which is you know has has been
a way of thinking for indigenous peoples
forever right to think about elements in
the landscape as our kin
um but it's something that is kind of
gaining traction right now and recently
the um the country of New Zealand
declared a mountain a person a legal
person right and these things are
happening more and more
um and so I like to think about
um uh that sense of personhood of when
you're on this mountain so we hope to
take this to more Mountains long story
short
I very much like a mountain being a
person than a corporation which is what
we do exactly
um I want to thank you so much thank you
thank you it's been so amazing thank you
very much
and there's your long enough challenge
going uh thank you and we'll clean up
the chairs and then we'll
be around for questions thank you
[Music]